invité de preuve par 3 François ripsamen
le président du groupe des sénateurs
socialistes et un proche de François
Hollande François bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous Karine Perret de la Agence
France Presse notre partenaire avec
Dailymotion et père internaute de Public
Sénat nous rejoindrons tout à l'heure au
cours de cette émission bien sûr qui
abordera et bien les difficultés de
l'action gouvernementale soulignées et
dit-on par D par le menteurs PS
eux-mêmes on verra si vous faites de
même ce soir avec nous françois-xamen ou
quoi que flottement de l'exécutif sur
les Roms sur la pose fiscale sur le
travail le dimanche répond une
surenchère des attaques de la droite qui
fait feu de tout bois notamment sur les
nouveaux rythmes scolaires tiens à
propos ceci sont entrés en vigueur dans
votre ville de Dijon vous avez fait ce
choix à la dernière rentrée est-ce que
vous faites le même bilan désastreux que
les parents d'élèves en tous les cas pas
à Dijon je peux pas généraliser mais ce
que je sais c'est qu'à Dijon la rentrée
s'est bien passée elle s'est bien passée
pour plusieurs raisons premièrement
parce que le gouvernement a remis des
postes dans l'Éducation nationale il
faut le rappeler c'est la première fois
depuis
1985 qu'à Dijon il y a des ouvertures de
classe avec un nombre d'élèves qui
augmente donc ça ça facilite bien sûr la
rentrée et les rythmes et les rythmes
ils se sont mis en place et ça
fonctionne bien nous venons d'en faire
un point bilan hier soir au conseil
municipal de Dijon et nous avons
constaté que dans toutes les écoles où
ces rythmes ont été mis en place ça se
passe bien que partout
peut-être ça se passe bien ailleurs
aussi président du MP qui considère que
cette réforme appliquée à la hâte mais
l'école à feu et à sang mais ça c'est du
côté dans le texte pourquoi je vous dis
ça parce que quand Jean-François Copé et
le gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy ont
décidé de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours sans prévenir personne on l'a
appris par une dépêche AFP un matin et
qu'il a fallu que toutes les s'organise
pour faire ce qu'on appelle l'accueil de
loisirs sans hébergement le mercredi
matin ça a coûté beaucoup d'argent aux
communes on sait pas poser la question à
ce moment-là et nous ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui c'est un constat d'échec de
cette loi de la semaine de 4 jours et ce
que ce qu'on veut mettre au cœur des
choses c'est l'élève et pour les lèvres
le rythme scolaire le qui est prôné par
les chronobiologistes par tous ceux qui
suivent cela qui se constate d'ailleurs
par comment dira un recul de plus en
plus important depuis 6 ou 7 ans des
capacités d'acquisition des
connaissances fondamentales lire écrire
compter et bien est dû à un rythme de
surcharge du des journées et donc
charge avec les activités de
périscolaires notamment en maternelle
ils sont pas plus fatigués à Dijon là
les petits mais pourquoi il y aura un
risque de surcharge ils ont parce que
nous on a un programme éducatif
territorial qui est en place depuis
longtemps on a préparé tout cela et dans
ce temps qu'on appelle le temps
périscolaire c'est-à-dire après le temps
de l'éducation nationale ils ont des
activités d'éveil des activités ludiques
encadrées par tous
sur le plan financier ça se passe bien
aussi pour pour votre commune c'est pas
trop lourd non c'est non c'est pas trop
lourd d'abord on est aidé par le fond
d'amorçage du gouvernement ensuite on a
aidé par les aides de la CAF qui a de la
Caisse d'allocations familiales qui
aborde les aides du gouvernement quand
il y a un vrai programme éducatif local
ce qui est notre cas
de vos collègues socialistes d'autres
grandes villes ont préféré attendre je
pense à Gérard Collomb à Lyon Martine
Aubry à Lille ils ont été prudents ou
réalistes peut-être la situation dans
ces communes là moi je me permets pas de
porter jugement j'étais avec Gérard
Collomb il y a quelques minutes il me
demandait comment ça se passait à Dijon
et je lui disais comment ça s'était
passé à prendre le train en marche à la
prochaine rentrée qu'est-ce qui peut
éviter aux parties socialiste un vote
sanction au prochain municipal et là on
quitte la ville de Dijon d'accord
je ne parlais pas je ne l'ai pas
répondre à Dijon à votre question
qu'est-ce qui peut éviter à votre
sanction le la qualité du travail et
fourni par nos mères j'irai même plus
loin vous voyez pour la première fois je
vais le dire par les mers en général les
maires sont aujourd'hui appréciées dans
la majorité des cas bien apprécié très
apprécié par quelque soit leur
étiquettes vous voulez dire oui je veux
dire en général les maires ce logo
germieux je veux dire avec un sourire
tout le monde comprendra bien sûr mais
les maires en général font bien leur
travail ils sont appréciés je pense que
ça se traduira quand même dans les
élections municipales vous le pensez ça
sera un facteur de résistance pour les
élus socialistes et sortant il y a quand
même beaucoup d'inquiétudes terminées
c'est un facteur de résistance et la
proximité de ces élus avec les habitants
des villes est aussi un facteur de
résistance à la montée des extrêmes
alors il y a beaucoup d'inquiétudes
néanmoins parmi les élus locaux parmi
les parlementaires PS également ces
derniers temps améliorées le budget qui
vient en discussion en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat et certains à la gauche du PS
vont même jusqu'à demander que l'on
renonce à augmenter la TVA le 1er
janvier prochain est-ce que vous vous
souvenez cette idée non les décisions
ont été prises elles ont été votées
d'ailleurs par ces mêmes parlementaires
il faut maintenant qu'il soit en
conformité avec leur propre vote donc on
n'est pas là dans le concours Lépine des
propositions fiscales la ligne du
gouvernement est claire il faut
redresser les comptes publics de la
France faut-il rappeler là il faut aider
la compétitivité des entreprises
justement si on paye plus de TVA à
partir de 1er janvier c'est pour
financer le crédit un peu compétitivité
des entreprises et donc la position est
simple et en même temps difficile à
tenir elle est simple à expliquer nous
sommes sur une ligne de crête la ligne
de crête c'est le chemin que nous devons
suivre pour redresser les comptes de la
France pour préserver l'emploi et pour
se préparer à la reprise de la
croissance de l'autre côté il y a le
versant de plus de rigueur plus de
rigueur plus de rigueur ça amène à une
politique d'austérité renforcée et de
l'autre côté il y a l'autre versant
c'est il faut relâcher l'effort et il
faut redistribuer et ça amène exactement
au même résultat et la décision la ligne
voulue par François Hollande c'est cette
ligne au milieu qui permet dans la
justice tout à la fois de redresser les
comptes progressivement puisque vous
savez moi je dois toujours aux
entreprises c'est de la politique de
l'offre les entreprises il faut il faut
c'est simple à expliquer mais on a
l'impression que c'est pas toujours
simple à assumer oui c'est pas facile
assumer d'habitude c'est vrai ce que
vous dites c'est pas facile à assumer
parce que la tradition veut que la
gauche soit redistributrice or il est
clair aujourd'hui que quand on arrive
vient de voir il faut que les
parlementaires socialistes se disent
quand on arrive au pouvoir après 10 ans
de droite c'est que la droite a
profondément échoué et que l'état de
notre pays ne nous permet pas de mener
une politique de redistribution à
assumer ce renoncement à cette politique
de distribution en attendant c'est pas
renoncement c'est une nécessité
aujourd'hui
d'avoir une politique de l'offre parce
que notre appareil productif a été
profondément profondément
détruit 750
000 emplois industriels
depuis 10 ans donc une politique de
relance aujourd'hui amènerait une
austérité renforcée quand vous dites
c'est difficile à assumer pour le chef
de l'État d'abord oui pour la gauche et
pour l'expliquer il faut expliquer les
choses il faut expliquer pourquoi on est
obligé de mener cette politique que les
fruits de cette politique prennent du
temps parce que on veut préserver
justement et l'emploi et la croissance
qui revient et donc pour faire cela il
faut attendre un peu on ne répare pas
mettez-moi cette formule un peu
lapidaire on ne répare pas en 18 mois ce
qui a été abîmé en disant vous dites
c'est pas le concours Lépine sur le plan
fiscal mais quand même il y a des
propositions qui vont imaginer des
parlementaires socialistes vous
peut-être on attend des coups de pouce
ils sont annoncés d'ailleurs on dit que
les parlementaires ont l'oreille de
Bercy par exemple est-ce qu'il faut
renoncer à baisser la TVA sur les
produits de première nécessité pour
augmenter par exemple la prime pour
l'emploi candidat la marche de manœuvre
que se garde les parlementaires
socialistes ils ont raison ils ont la
possibilité de discuter du texte que
présente le gouvernement à la marge à la
marge je dis bien à la marge et s'ils
ont des propositions et j'en doute pas
intelligentes à formuler elles peuvent
être prises alors vous dites il faut
assumer la politique qui est suivie
décidé par le chef de l'État un mot sur
les retraites puisqu'on a appris
aujourd'hui que le document envoyé par
la France à Bruxelles pour définir mais
comme il est privé maintenant sa
stratégie de politique économique
reconnaît sa document officiel de Paris
reconnaît que l'âge de départ à la
retraite va faire un bon après
l'allongement à 43 ans la durée de
cotisation donc là je légale reste
officiellement à 62 ans mais là je réel
en fait pour partir avec une retraite à
taux plein et bien sera de 66 ans et ça
c'est écrit noir sur blanc pourquoi ne
pas assumer à Paris ce que l'on dit à
Bruxelles
les choses le départ officiel de
possibilité de partir à la retraite à 62
ans nous avons avec une pension j'y
viens nous avons décidé d'allonger
progressivement à partir de 2020 la
durée de cotisation qui passera de 41
nets à nuité et demi à 43 années en 2030
en 2030 effectivement si l'âge moyen
d'entrer dans la vie active et de 23 ans
ceux qui auront cotisé 43 ans auront une
retraite à taux plein à 66 ans en 2030
mais nous avons pris un certain nombre
de mesures pour amonier cela et il faut
le rappeler le
la possibilité de prendre en compte la
pénibilité des des travaux qui permet de
racheter trimestre pour les étudiants et
pour les jeunes il en est de même avec
la possibilité de racheter des
trimestres et donc 66 ans en 2030 ça
sera le maximum quand on aura regardé ce
qui a été fait pour la pénibilité et
pour les jeunes rentrer plus tard dans
la vie active on s'apercevra ça sera pas
la généralités on dit aujourd'hui que un
Français sur deux peu par rapport à
partir avant 62 ans le problème
aujourd'hui essentiel vous le savez
d'ailleurs très bien c'est pas l'âge à
laquelle ils peuvent partir à la traite
c'est la possibilité de travailler
jusqu'à la retraite pour les personnes
qui sont d'ailleurs les plus
âgées dans l'entreprise parce qu'elle
perd elle perdent leur emploi bien
souvent à 55 ans 57 ans ou 58 est-ce que
vous avez compris le flottement du
gouvernement sur le travail le dimanche
en temporise parce que les ministres ne
sont pas tous d'accord et on se dit
rendez-vous dans deux mois pourtant
dossier on le connaît
décider la droite n'a pas pu le régler
vous le savez bien Luc Châtel que
j'écoutais dernièrement reconnaissait
qu'il j'ai fait une loi qui n'était pas
ce qu'il fallait faire donc il faut
qu'on modifie cette loi donc il faut
trouver faut rappeler les principes le
repos dominical reste un principe faut
rappeler quand même que près de 30% des
salariés travaillent le dimanche dans
les emplois de la sécurité des
transports de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration etc
occasionnellement beaucoup
occasionnellement c'est vrai enfin la
sécurité c'est quand même dans la santé
c'est souvent quand même le dimanche et
puis il faut donner un peu de souplesse
je pense que ce sera la preuve la
proposition que fera monsieur Bailly
puisque il va faire des propositions
d'ici 6 semaines ça va aller vite faut
de la souplesse je pense pour les zones
touristiques il faut de la souplesse
pour ces zones d'urbanisme commercial
qui sont des zones absolues
exceptionnelles dans un certain nombre
de villes voilà les voilà les qualités
de la souplesse qu'il faut avoir mais il
faut toujours avoir un souci de
préserver les salariés de l'emploi
salarié est-ce que vous me permettez
encore deux secondes de remarque là où
ça a été libéralisé totalement parce que
j'ai regardé cela que ce soit en Italie
que ce soit en Espagne la libéralisation
était totale du travail du dimanche ça a
été une destruction d'emplois massifs
dans le petit commerce donc nous on ne
veut pas de cela d'accord un député
socialiste dénonce les ministres qui se
comportent dit-il en enfant gâté de la
République le Gouvernement c'est
l'équipe de France de Nice en référence
à la Coupe du monde en Afrique du Sud et
c'est signé Jean-Christophe cambadéli
c'est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec sa
vision je veux dire autrement je veux
dire qu'il faut un peu plus de sens
collectif voilà
il faut jouer collectivement c'est à
dire qu'il faut pas essayer de tirer la
couverture à soi pour se mettre en
valeur on est dans une ambition
collective celle de redresser la France
et nous le faisons que le Président de
la République donc on doit être
respectueux de la fonction qu'on a c'est
une occasion pour moi de le dire à tous
les miss je jouais collectifs jusqu'à la
prochaine fois oui mais vous savez il y
a dans un gouvernement des personnalités
elles ont le droit aussi de s'exprimer
mais elles n'ont pas le droit de rompre
l'engagement collectif
non je ne pense pas je voudrais pas
mettre en cause vraiment de monnaie
du chef de l'État
certains lui reprochent à nouveau
aujourd'hui de ne pas assumer certaines
de ces décisions sa vie politique et
surtout son autorité ces critiques ont
resurgies avec le bras de fer évidemment
entre Cécile Duflot Emmanuel Valls on va
en parler dans un instant est-ce que ce
procès totalement est fondé il est fondé
président de la République et quelqu'un
qui a de l'autorité qui s'est décidé
quand il faut décider on l'a vu à
l'occasion des crises internationales
parce que sur le terrain à
l'international il est le seul à décider
c'est simple c'est son pouvoir il est le
chef des armées il décide donc cet homme
sait décider et à l'intérieur d'une
société qui a été je vais vous faire
l'analyse de François Hollande qui a été
profondément traumatisée par 50
sarkozymes où on a opposé les uns aux
autres son souci est de rassembler et de
rassembler les Français pour les
rassembler il a une politique une
méthode qui est différente de celle de
Nicolas Sarkozy et donc il n'est pas
pour trancher dans le vif tous les jours
tous les matins tous les sujets
vous avez vu les sondages je vois mais
il s'attendait pas à être populaire si
il est impopulaire aujourd'hui et il est
je ne le nie pas bien évidemment s'il a
un populaire c'est à cause de la
situation économique et donc ça cote se
redressera avec la baisse du chômage
espérant que il y a pas de trafic de SFR
sur les chiffres du chômage ça colle sur
redressera avec cela ça coûte ça
m'adressera avec la France qui se
redresse je vais vous livrer l'analyse
de François hollandais vous nous dites
qu'il est tranquille et inoxydable oui
serein inoxydable mais bien évidemment
sensible à l'impatience à l'impatience
des Français qui est là oui bien sûr
parce que c'est difficile de dire aux
Français nous je vous demande encore de
faire des efforts faites des efforts
supplémentaires mais ça va prendre du
temps ça prend du temps c'est vrai alors
le summum dans le manque d'esprit
collectif comme vous dites ça mène a été
atteint évidemment par Manuel Valls et
Cécile Duflot sur les rhum un débat que
le premier ministre tranche à sa manière
en disant que l'intégration est possible
si les lois sont respectées avant
d'accueillir Karine Perret de l'Agence
France Presse Jér ôme Rabier nous
présente l'offensif tous azimut du
ministre de l'Intérieur douce d'ailleurs
a beaucoup d'élus locaux en prévision
des municipales comme une majorité de
Français d'ailleurs les sondages le
montrent là
il est le ministre préféré des Français
et pourtant il déclenche la polémique
jusque dans sa propre majorité moins de
six mois avant les élections municipales
Manuel Valls c'est déjà pourtant très
sollicité par les candidats socialistes
à ces élections cette politique
justification si elle est si bien perçue
par l'ensemble des maires de l'ensemble
des territoires de France c'est parce
qu'elle correspond à une réalité ces
élus locaux ont d'ailleurs publié une
tribune ce week-end pour soutenir son
action car dans leur municipalité ils
peuvent parfois se retrouver confrontés
à des campements illicites et à
l'exaspération de leurs administrer
Manuel Valls répond aujourd'hui à la
demande des élus comme moi quant au bout
des procédures judiciaires il y a
l'exécution des décisions de justice à
mettre en oeuvre donc avec la force
publique donc il fait tout simplement il
assume ses responsabilités de ministre
de l'intérieur mais ce discours qui se
veut faire meurt également de nombreuses
voix dans la majorité qui préféreraient
que d'autres thèmes soient mis en avant
dans la campagne qui commence
des problèmes de dans leur territoire
bien sûr quand ta mère a des problèmes
de campement faut traiter le problème
mais il faut mettre en oeuvre la
circulaire pas besoin d'aller claironner
partout dans le France entière pour
20.000 personnes donc bien sûr que les
élus ont besoin d'être entendus mais pas
seulement avant les municipales à
l'heure où les partis politiques
cherchent la réponse au Front national
la droite soutien les propos de Manuel
Valls tout en critiquant son action bien
consciente qu'il représente une gauche
qui ne veut plus laisser le thème de la
sécurité à la droite nous nous disons la
même chose que lui sauf que nous nous
réaliserions des choses concrètement et
que lui pour le moment ne peut pas les
réaliser il y a pas de raison qui nous
gêne à droite on est tenté de dire
chiche fait le refusant de le rappeler
alors comme Cécile Duflot le lui
demandait François Hollande confirme
qu'il compte sur son ministre de
l'Intérieur pour monter au front sur ce
sujet qui ne risque pas de retomber
avant les prochaines échéances
électorales
voilà Karine Perret de l'Agence France
Presse est avec nous Karine bonsoir vos
questions à François Rebsamen alors
dimanche il y a eu un texte de soutien
de 16 élus un soutien à Manuel Valls qui
considère que que son action contre les
campements illicites de Rome et tout à
fait fondé ce texte vous le signez j'ai
pas vu votre signature moi je signe j'ai
pas de problème bien sûr que l'action de
Manuel Valls c'est tout à fait fondé
quand il démantèle des campements de
Rome sur qui sont en situation
d'illégalité qui occupe indument des
terrains privés bien sûr il applique la
loi républicaine et il a raison est-ce
que vous pensez que Manuel Valls a mis
en cause justement le pacte républicain
comme l'a dit sa collègue du
gouvernement Cécile Duflot je pense que
pour la situation des Roms dans notre
pays la ligne juste la bonne ligne c'est
celle de la circulaire du mois d'août
2012 c'est-à-dire il faut la fermeté la
plus républicaine la plus à l'égard de
ceux qui aujourd'hui sont dans
l'illégalité et donc il faut démanteler
les campements de Rome je suis pas voilà
et quitte à renvoyer dans leur pays ceux
qui alimentent les réseaux mafieux parce
qu'il y en a autour de ces campements
bien souvent ceux qui pratiquent qui ne
respectent pas les lois de la République
mais l'autre côté je voudrais le dire
ici c'est que pour ceux qui souhaitent
s'insérer il faut les aider à
l'insertion
par le ministre de l'Intérieur il
considère que dans leur immense majorité
les Roms ne peuvent pas s'intégrer alors
là vous le signer là aussi comme le
texte de soutien je ne dirais pas les
choses comme ça
je ne dirais pas les choses comme ça je
dirais qu'une grande majorité une grande
majorité de Rome c'est vrai ne veulent
pas s'intégrer mais je ne dirais pas que
tous les Roms ne veulent pas s'intégrer
et donc ceux qui veulent aussi
c'est l'immense majorité c'est vrai
qu'une grande majorité alors immense ou
grande majorité une grande majorité sont
prêts je le crois à s'insérer à
condition qu'on leur donne les moyens de
l'insertion
j'ai remarquéro qui disait que
l'intégration était possible donc il y a
une contradiction entre le Premier
ministre et son ministre de l'Intérieur
qui dit vrai Emmanuel Valls
des populations immigrées il est chargé
de faire appliquer la loi républicaine
quand il y a égalité de campement Rome
tous les matins il y a des mères qui
l'appelle pour lui demander de
démanteler des campements Rome donc il
le fait dans la mesure des possibilités
quand on en a une décision de justice et
qu'il applique la décision de justice il
y a aux portes de Paris un campement
Rome ou pour le moment on peut pas
obtenir des décisions de justice parce
que les terrains appartiennent à
multipropriété et donc c'est difficile
parce qu'il faut que le propriétaire du
terrain demande lui-même l'évacuation
donc quand il le fait dans le cas de la
loi républicaine avec fermeté et
humanité moi je soutiens totalement
Emmanuel Valls mais je dis que quand des
familles Rome souhaitent s'insérer dans
notre pays on doit les aider à
l'insertion
depuis quelques mois comment ça se passe
comment vous pouvez
gros gros campement Rome
une minorité a souhaité s'insérer sont
des familles avec l'enfant les enfants
sur scolarisés et nous accompagnons ces
familles qui souhaitent s'insérer dans
notre école
souvent des familles vous savez on
repère assez vite dans les campements
Rome ceux qui sont ce qu'on appelle à la
tête de réseau qui font mendier les
femmes qui empêchent les enfants des
scolarisés et donc pour cela excusez-moi
de l'expression pas de pitié à voir il
ne respecte pas la loi républicaine
quand des familles de bonne foi veulent
s'insérer mais faut les aider à le faire
les insérer c'est les sauver de la mamie
des groupes mafieux oui bien sûr c'est
les sortir c'est les sortir de la misère
c'est leur donner des conditions de vie
descente comme on le doit à toute
personne surtout quand il y a des
enfants c'est scolarisé
les enfants c'est accompagné par
l'assistanat social ces familles c'est
ce que nous faisons à Dijon je ne donne
pas des gens forcément un exemple ça se
passe bien mais c'est vrai ce que dit
manuel est juste Manuel Valls pardon est
juste une grande majorité ne veut pas
s'insérer ça c'est clair
les écologistes ce sont des alliés
difficiles vous l'avez vu au Sénat ils
ont refusé certains de voter certains
textes est-ce que comme un certain
nombre de membres du gouvernement vous
jugez que il y en a marre des
écologistes qui commencent à bien faire
est-ce qu'ils sont à boulets non
partenaire les écologistes sur les
partenaires les partenaires
j'emploierai pas le mot turbulent c'est
des partenaires qui parfois sont
agaçants sont agaçants pour la majorité
mais ils sont agaçants pour eux-mêmes
s'ils se regardent bien c'est à dire que
il faut que il ramène aussi de l'ordre
chez eux il faut qu'ils arrêtent de
tourner mais pour le moment sur les
textes essentiels le soutien au budget
parce que c'est quand même l'acte majeur
les écologistes ont toujours été là
maintenant faut qu'il remettent aussi un
peu d'ordre dans la maison écologiste ça
c'est clair mais est-ce que une ministre
peut en appeler comme ça publiquement à
l'arbitrage de François Hollande alors
que il est ce jour-là à Florange ça lui
gâche complètement sa journée il
essayait de se rabibaucher avec les
salariés les syndicats est-ce que vous
qui êtes un proche de l'état vous
confirmez qu'il a été très très
en colère
oui il était heureux de montrer sa
capacité à aller à nouveau dialoguer
avec les salariés à Florange et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas donné de réponse à
cette interpellation
finalement été furieux mais ça n'a pas
été conséquence sur le l'auteur de la
phrase il ne répond pas ou de
l'interpellation sexuelle il va pas
répondre à des injonctions le président
de la République il dira ce qu'il a à
dire le moment venu
il y a pas de réponse la seule réponse
c'est finalement parce qu'elle Durand
qui va partir de la tête du parti et
puis c'est tout le parti écologiste il
se gère à sa manière c'est pas nous on a
rien à y voir dedans de la gestion du
mais ça me permet de leur demander de
mettre un peu d'ordre dans leur propre
maison vous dites que ce sont des
partenaires turbulents quand il a
apporté à la majorité présidentielle
ils apportent une vision de de la gauche
qui une vision importante maintenant ils
peuvent gâcher assez vite par des prises
de position
qui sont contradictoires on va dire par
des prises de position de leur capital
électorales de sympathie on a vu ce qui
s'est passé avec les grenades en
Allemagne ou
ils avaient commencé très haut et ils
sont en train de descendre donc je les
appelle pour eux d'ailleurs pour nous
pour la gauche à retrouver leurs esprits
et à être unis par exemple toutes les
initiatives de la ministre du Logement
vous êtes maire de Dijon vous suivez
très près le dossier de l'immobilier par
exemple est-ce que vous pensez ce que sa
loi
est favorable au logement
je la soutiens on apportera des
améliorations bien sûr mais je soutiens
la première loi qu'elle avait présenté
en effet d'ailleurs d'écouter c'était
gardé sénateurs sur les suites de la loi
puisqu'il y a eu un problème
constitutionnel mais il y a aujourd'hui
dans la loi allure qui est la nouvelle
loi sur le logement qu'elle présente
tout un tas de dispositifs qui ont été
étudiés qui ont été étudiés qui sont
étudiés en ce moment par les sénateurs
qui correspondent à ce qu'on attend on a
besoin dans ce pays de construire des
logements locatifs à loyer modéré elle
fait tout pour que ça se passe bien elle
est donc une bonne ministre du logement
dans sa fonction de ministre du Logement
parce que finalement le malheur de
François Hollande dans la gestion du
quotidien avec les écologistes c'est pas
cet accord de mandature qui a été signé
en 2011 entre Cécile Duflot et Martine
Aubry qui étaient alors la numéro 1 du
PS
est-ce que effectivement François
Hollande est victime de cet accord
électoral que Martine Aubry en s'entend
avait passé avec les écologistes on peut
aussi à contrario par rapport à ce que
ce sourire que j'ai exprimais on peut
aussi considérer je le fais que l'accord
avec les écologistes a permis la
victoire parce qu'il faut d'abord
assembler c'est toujours la logique
électorale elle n'a pas changé il faut
d'abord rassembler son camp ensuite
rassembler la gauche pour les gens de
gauche bien évidemment et donc les
écologistes en font partie
incontestablement ils ont leur place
dans le gouvernement mais à condition de
respecter eux aussi une sorte de
discipline collective qui peut qui peut
leur imposer le respect de la discipline
qui qui qui qui ne se passe son job là
c'est le chef de l'État c'est le premier
ministre non mais c'est là je parlais
pas uniquement du gouvernement je
parlais à l'intérieur de leur partie
donc voilà c'est leur resp c'est pour ça
que je les appelle à prendre ses
responsabilités là
je reviens à Manuel Valls à droite on a
Nicolas Sarkozy qui a fait campagne qui
fait encore campagne en disant qu'il est
le seul rempart contre le Front national
en vue des élections des prochaines
municipales est-ce que vous pensez que
Manuel Valls peut être celui qui
sera bimoche avec un électorat qui
pourrait être tenté par le vote Front
national son travail de ministre et bien
fait il le fait de manière
professionnelle dans un cadre
républicain donc c'est un atout un
contestable pour la gauche mais moi je
continue
je considère au contraire que le
meilleur moyen pour nous de gagner des
municipalités ou de conserver nos
municipalités c'est le travail de nos
élus locaux et s'ils peuvent s'appuyer
sur le travail national fait par Manuel
Valls tant mieux et c'est ce qui se
produira mais la victoire si la victoire
au municipales où le maintien de nos
positions ce qui serait déjà bien vu le
nombre de municipalités que nous avons
elle ne sera pas due uniquement Manuel
Valls il y a une multitude de facteurs
et le premier des facteurs c'est le
travail des locaux c'est le point c'est
la qualité du travail des mers c'est ça
qui va être jugé c'est ça qu'il faut
juger en même temps c'est fort bien
quand il applique la loi républicaine
mais c'est pas facile pour lui je le dis
ici c'est pas facile pour lui les camps
de Rome ils sont pas apparus en 2012
quand nous sommes arrivés ils étaient là
depuis longtemps ils sont bien souvent
en kysté sur le territoire et donc c'est
pas facile de les démanteler et il faut
le faire avec fermeté comme il le fait
mais aussi avec l'humanité tandis que le
bilan de la sécurité n'est pas bon avec
la progression de la délinquance est-ce
que je conteste ces chiffres qui ont
complètement je comptais ces chiffres je
pense que avec les zones de sécurité
prioritaire tout un travail est fait qui
permet de réussite on a vu des saisies
d'armes
importante de drogue mais il y a c'est
vrai
mais vous savez il y a eu moins ça c'est
l'aspect médiatique des choses s'il y
avait peut-être un reproche mais il fait
son travail professionnel c'est que à
force de venir à chaque fois qu'il y a
un meurtre à Marseille on croit qu'il y
a plus de meurtres que l'année d'avant
alors là nous avons il y avait plus de
merde vous me direz c'est pas mieux
qu'il y en ait euh
s'économise un petit peu dans ces
déplacements Paris Marseille ou qui
rappelle qu'il y en avait encore plus
l'année d'avant ce qui n'est pas quand
même une garantie en soi de victoire
parce que il y en a toujours de trop
bien sûr d'accord merci Karine Perrine
Arnaud Public Sénat elle va arriver pour
la dernière partie de l'émission où il
sera notamment question et bien du cumul
des mandats alors on l'a entendu depuis
le début d'émission à force de soi-même
vous demandez que l'on sert les rangs
derrière le chef de l'État mais quand
même vous vous distinguez à votre
manière un dossier dans lequel on
retrouve d'ailleurs l'intraitable Manuel
Valls Faustine Saint-Geniès
le Barou de déshonneur la faute du Sénat
des sénateurs qui votent le nom cumul
sauf pour eux c'est peut dire que
l'image de l'institution a été ternie
après le vote où le sur le nom cumul des
mandats les sénateurs se sont donnés le
droit de cumuler leur mandat avec un
mandat exécutif local contrairement au
députés une campagne de dénigrement que
ne comprend pas alain GOURNAC pour lui
l'encrage local c'est ce qui fait la
spécificité du Sénat nous nous sommes
issus du territoire nous sommes nous
respirons la France tout le temps de
respirons terrain et c'est cette
respiration qui nous permet aujourd'hui
de ne pas être théorique des sénateurs
partisans du cumulus mais par nécessité
insiste Françoise okto pour lui si le
Sénat perdait son ancrage territorial il
serait amené à disparaître il servira à
rien d'avoir deux chambres qui soient
identiques l'Assemblée nationale si elle
était
identique au Sénat je vois pas le hé
réciproquement je vois pas du tout
l'intérêt
donc il faut que le Sénat soit
spécifique et qu'il soit le représentant
des territoires autre grief leurs
indemnités les sénateurs sont défendent
cumuler les mandats ne veut pas dire
cumuler les revenus dans le texte adopté
au Sénat ils ont ajouté un amendement
spécifique une innovation par rapport au
texte voté à l'Assemblée nationale en
cas de cumul les sénateurs ne percevront
que leur indemnité de parlementaire une
économie selon pour l'état du point de
vue de la morale comme du point de vue
des finances l'économie n'est pas dans
le non-cumul et pour montrer encore
davantage leur bonne volonté les
sénateurs ont même proposé de limiter
les mandats dans le temps un amendement
désapprouvé par le gouvernement et qui a
été rejeté
une bonsoir grande question à Françoise
samen on l'a vu dans ce sujet il y a une
incompréhension totale de la position
des sénateurs par l'opinion comment vous
vous avez vécu cette période j'ai pas
été une période facile parce que
la position que adopter une position de
conviction que j'ai exprimé il y a fort
longtemps parce que je considère que
dans le fonctionnement de nos
institutions le Sénat qui représente les
collectivités territoriales de la
République qui sont élus par des mers
devraient pouvoir ou vont pouvoir on
verra devrait pouvoir cumuler un mandat
de maire en l'occurrence un mandat
exécutif local et un seul et le faire
même de manière bénévole parce que je
pense que l'expertise
ça peut faire sourire vous savez si je
voulais être dans l'air du temps je
dirais exactement le contraire parce que
c'est pas ça qui m'amène de la
popularité c'est le moment qu'on puisse
dire surtout qu'on peut être brocardé
facilement donc moi c'est un combat de
conviction pour le fonctionnement de nos
institutions pour la qualité de la loi
je veux dire pour la qualité de la loi
qui est faite je pense que quand on est
maire quand on sait comment fonctionne
une mairie quand on voit la réalité de
l'application de la loi sur le terrain
et ça on ne le voit pas quand on est
conseillé municipal quand on le voit en
tant que mère et bien on fait des
meilleures lois comme ça plusieurs fois
au Parlement mais je pense que souvent
ce sont les élus qui cumulent qui sont
le plus présents donc vous considérez
j'étais au cabinet de Piaggio Scott la
loi a été adoptée en 1983 qui donne le
droit à l'information c'est le droit à
l'information des minorités dans les
conseils mais c'est pourquoi on n'est
pas dans l'exécutif d'une collectivité
locale on ne met pas en œuvre
concrètement les lois et donc ce qui
donne cette expertise c'est le fait de
mettre en oeuvre concrètement les lois
quand on ne sait pas comment on fait
pour construire un logement pour lancer
des zones d'aménagement concertés et
bien on prend des lois qui sont des fois
un décalage avec la réalité elles sont
moins efficaces et cette expertise qui
peut être complétée bien sûr par la
position de l'Assemblée c'était ou
tranchée cette expertise elle est
importante pour faire des lois qui
soient des lois efficaces Gérard Collomb
a proposé la semaine dernière de faire
du Sana à un espèce de bundos rat une
assemblée des élus locaux à l'allemande
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à cette
évolution du Sana à partir du moment où
vous perdez cette spécificité j'ai pensé
à ça c'est un beau débat qui mériterait
c'est ça que j'ai reproché au fond
finalement à cette loi sur le cumul
c'est qu'elle arrive de manière un peu
excusez-moi l'expression un peu sèche
comme ça sans avoir eu une réflexion
globale le président du Sénat je
voudrais le dire Jean-Pierre le
président le président du Sénat qui est
d'ailleurs un ami et je voudrais lui
affirmer ici Jean-Pierre Bel mon soutien
plutôt total face à des attaques
personnelles dont il a été l'objet et
bien le président du Sénat il a une
position sur une conception du
bicamérisme Jean-Pierre Gérard Collomb
et moi j'avais émis aussi cette idée on
a eu une conception d'un bkrisme
différent c'est un vrai débat qui mérite
d'être mené et d'ailleurs moi je
proposerai après tout ça peut-être une
réflexion sur les institutions que nous
devrions avoir et quel est le risque
pour le Sénat de disparaître comme on a
pu l'entendre dans le reportage à partir
du moment
je pense que c'est pour être une chambre
on dit des choses quand même sans savoir
ce que je regrette c'est que la
représentation des collectivités
territoriales ne sera pas ass de la même
manière par des sénateurs qui ne seront
pas en responsabilité d'exécutif locaux
on enlève vous l'avez bien fait de le
signaler vous avez bien fait de le
signaler on enlève la partie cumul des
indemnités qui fait que beaucoup de la
population beaucoup de personnes pensent
que c'est pour cumuler les indemnités
puisque ça sera un mandat bénévole le
mandat exécutif local et puis on
réfléchit au fonctionnement de nos
institutions est-ce que ça entraînerait
la disparition du Sénat je ne le crois
pas je ne le crois pas pour autant il
faut pas non plus forcer le trait mais
je pense que son rôle serait à Moinerie
dans la relation
vous donne de dire votre
soutien en ce moment ce contexte
particulier ou votre propre majorité
fait un peu la figuration au Sénat avec
le gouvernement ne tient pas compte un
peu de cette majorité de vos textes ici
d'abord je voudrais dire qu'il y a eu
une campagne ce qu'on appelle couramment
mais tout le monde comprendra du Sénat
bashing le Sénat serait une assemblée
démodée etc
parce que sur le cumul on a pris cette
position on entend le gouvernement pour
certains aussi font du Sénat bashing
je pense que on attend beaucoup de
choses qui se disent très désagréables
sur le Sénat c'est pour moi l'occasion
de rappeler dans les médias sur les
réseaux sociaux sur les réseaux sociaux
dans la dans la presse où effectivement
enfin bon peu importe donc moi je
voudrais dire quand même que nous avons
voté des lois qui montrent la modernité
du Sénat nous avons voté la loi même si
ça fait pas plaisir de le rappeler qui
donne le droit de vote aux étrangers en
situation régulière dans notre pays
après tout l'assemblée peut le faire
aussi maintenant puisque nous l'avons
voté et puis nous avons voté le mariage
pour tous on a voté donc des lois qui
sont des lois qu'on pourrait dire comme
ça de modernité en tous les cas autre
importante sont aussi on a vu l'année
dernière pour le loi de finances ici
n'est pas passé la majorité
en même temps mais vous le savez très
bien la majorité sénatoriale n'est pas
la même que la majorité gouvernementale
le groupe communiste qui nous a donné
cette majorité avec les autres groupes
qui nous a donné cette majorité qui a
permis l'élection de Jean-Pierre Bel ne
participent pas au gouvernement de la
République au gouvernement de Jean-Marc
Ayrault et donc il vote comme il
l'entend de suivant les textes et donc
il n'y a pas concordance entre la
majorité gouvernementale et la majorité
je pense que vous savez si le Sénat
était je l'ai dit à Jean-Marc Ayraud si
le Sénat était vraiment dans
l'opposition le gouvernement verrait la
difficulté donc alors il verrait la
difficulté parce que mais il est présent
le gouvernement beaucoup plus qu'il ne
l'était sous François Fillon je crois
pas que François Fillon nous a fait
l'honneur de venir souvent aux questions
d'actualité au Sénat qui ont marqué au
le fait j'ai envie de vous poser la même
question que tout à l'heure à propos des
écologistes Martine Aubry est-ce que
vous ne vous sentez pas lié par cet
engagement de François Hollande sur le
nom cumul parce que c'est une promesse
en fait qui a été arraché aux candidats
par Martin Aubry à l'époque
moi j'ai j'ai dit à François Hollande je
j'ai dit à François Hollande que je
n'étais pas d'accord avec cette
proposition que c'était ma conviction
profonde je lui ai dit d'autant plus
facilement je peux permettre je sais pas
de dégager ma responsabilité je l'ai
assumé mais je lui ai dit d'autant plus
facilement que je savais que ce texte
passerait pas au Sénat puisqu'il n'y
avait pas de majorité pour cela on va
dire un
mot d'une désir c'est vrai on entend
beaucoup les ministres on entend les
parlementaires mais le Parti socialiste
lui est assez muet absent de la scène
politique est-ce que vous auriez Harlem
Désir à se réveiller et à se manifester
un peu plus
élections municipales c'est le rôle du
parti désigne les candidats
une fonction il le fait de manière plus
discrète ce qui est vrai c'est que le
Parti socialiste a été en quelque sorte
était avec le départ de du meilleur de
meilleur d'entre eux au gouvernement et
donc faut qu'il se remette en marche oui
mais papa
socialiste se remette en mouvement
autour de Harlem Désir il y a des
secrétaires nationaux il faut qu'ils
assument leur responsabilité tous
collectivement et c'est pas facile parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas l'habitude de le
faire le virage à droite de François
Bayrou est-ce qu'il vous handicape à
Dijon ou des élus modernes font partie
de votre majorité oui des élus modernes
font partie de majorité
pour la prochaine campagne
je rassemble la gauche j'assemble les
socialistes je rassemble à gauche et sur
la base de mon programme Vienne ceux qui
souhaitent venir et donc dans les
parties républicains et donc bien
évidemment les les élus MoDem centrist
de François beroux avait souhaité me
rejoindre sur la base de notre programme
oui François Hollande de ne pas l'avoir
fait avec François Bayrou non parce que
je pense c'est qu'on aurait pu
effectivement peut-être à un moment
prendre plus de ne plus de considération
à François Bayrou je sais pas si ça
aurait changé je sais pas si ça aurait
changé je suis pas sûr que c'était le
mieux
non mais enfin je pense que quand il y a
quelqu'un qui a appelé à voter pour vous
je pense qu'il faut le considérer voilà
donc des regrets des
on aurait pu faire les choses
responsable de son virage à droite
aujourd'hui non non
il est assez grand pour s'assumer quand
on a quand on a des convictions voilà et
d'ailleurs il explique que maintenant
c'est justement parce que François
Hollande est trop à gauche que il est
avec Borlo je pense c'est un vrai
centriste François Bayrou c'est un vrai
centriste il y en a pas beaucoup des
vrais de vrais c'est-à-dire ni gauche ni
droite bah oui c'est ce qu'il a pratiqué
jusqu'à présent
à droite c'est à dire que il ne veut
plus d'alliance pour les municipales
à Dijon comme ailleurs après tout ils
participent à l'exécutif municipal s'ils
veulent continuer ça dépend de la
semaine dernière Éric de Ligier sénateur
UMP avait fait part de ses instincts
meurtrier à l'égard de François Hollande
et de sa banque c'était des paroles
publiques lors des journées
parlementaires de l'UMP
Eric belligé ne s'est pas excusé est-ce
que vous avez discuté avec lui vous
l'avez parlé au téléphone
j'ai vu avec un peu de stupéfaction
cette déclaration qui peut être tenue
pour des propos
j'allais dire presque d'après bancaire
des choses comme ça mais je voudrais
attirer l'attention de du sénateur de
Ligier sur la portée de ses propos parce
que ça s'adresse bien souvent l'ensemble
de la population quand ils sont repris
publiquement et il y a des esprits
faibles et ça peut avoir un impact sur
des esprits faibles et je trouve
intolérable ce type de propos dans la
démocratie apaisée que nous souhaitons
qu'on souhaite au Sénat et ailleurs et
bien il faut se respecter puis je dirais
au sénateur de léger qu'il va falloir
qu'il prenne son mal en patience parce
que on est là pour 5 ans et donc s'il en
est à vouloir avoir des instincts
meurtriers au bout d'un an et demi
qu'est-ce qu'il fera au bout de 4 ans
donc je l'appelle à revenir à des choses
tout à fait
de l'humour
c'était plus que borderline
la réaction de Gaudin je l'avais pas vu
mais c'était
moi j'ai de l'humour je le dis à
Jean-Claude Gaudin
merci d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine merci Perrine
bonsoir à tous et à très vite